♫ ♫
>> I AM OPTIMISTIC THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO REACH AN AGREEMENT.
>> I HAVE DISCUSSED SOME OF THE
OUTLINES WITH MY CAUCUS THAT I
THINK WE ARE VERY HAPPY WITH,
AND HOPEFULLY THE REPUBLICANS
ARE.
AND THEN WE CAN GET SOMETHING
REALLY GOOD DONE.
>> THE ONLY REASON WE DON’T HAVE
A BUDGET AGREEMENT IS BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO HOLD
FUNDING FOR THE GOVERNMENT
HOSTAGE.
>> IF WE DON’T CHANGE THE
LEGISLATION, IF WE DON’T GET RID
OF THESE LOOPHOLES WHERE KILLERS
ARE ALLOWED TO COME INTO OUR
COUNTRY AND CONTINUE TO KILL, IF
WE DON’T CHANGE IT, LET’S HAVE A
SHUTDOWN.
WE WILL DO A SHUTDOWN.
IT’S WORTH IT FOR OUR COUNTRY.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE A SHUTDOWN
IF WE DON’T GET THIS STUFF TAKEN
CARE OF.
>> Shannon: PRETTY SPICY WORDS
FROM ALL OVER ON THE ISSUE.
RIGHT NOW LIVE ON THE HOUSE
FLOOR, THEY ARE VOTING ON THE
STOPGAP SPENDING MEASURE,
ANOTHER SHORT-TERM MEASURE TO
GET TO MARCH 23.
WE WILL KEEP YOU UPDATED.
LET’S BRING THE PANEL.
FOX NEWS MEDIA ANALYST
HOWARD KURTZ, AUTHOR OF THE NEW
BOOK "MEDIA MADNESS."
RACHAEL BADE, CONGRESSIONAL
REPORTER FOR POLITICO.
JONATHAN SWANN, NATIONAL
POLITICAL REPORTER FOR AXIOS.
THERE’S A LOT OF BACK-AND-FORTH
ON THIS ISSUE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE A SHUTDOWN IF WE DON’T
GET THIS TAKEN CARE OF.
JONATHAN, WHO GOT BLAMED LAST
TIME?
WHO WILL GET BLAMED THIS TIME?
>> DEMOCRATS CLEARLY GOT BLAMED
LAST TIME SOME OF THEM ANYWAY
REGRET THE WAY IT PANNED OUT.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP KEEPS SAYING
THIS, IT’S VERY HARD FOR THE
REPUBLICANS TO CLAIM IT’S A
DEMOCRATIC SHUTDOWN.
I MADE A FEW PHONE CALLS AFTER
THOSE COMMENTS TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT HAPPENED.
WAS THERE A GRAND STRATEGY?
SEEMS NOT TO.
THE CONSENSUS SEEMS TO BE IT WAS
AN EMOTIONAL REACTION.
WE’VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT DEATHS
OF PEOPLE AT THE HANDS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
I DON’T KNOW THAT THIS WAS THAT
PARTICULARLY STRATEGIC COMMENT
MADE BY THE PRESIDENT.
>> Shannon: THE CONVERSATION
TODAY AT THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
ABOUT MS-13 AND OUTLINING SOME
REALLY HORRIFIC CASES.
>> PEOPLE FORGET THE PRESIDENT
REALLY MEANS THIS STUFF.
HE REALLY CARES ABOUT THIS STUFF
AND HE THOUGHT ABOUT IT FOR
YEARS.
IT’S NOT LIKE HEALTH CARE WHERE
HE HASN’T REALLY HAD FULLY
FORMED THOUGHTS.
HE REALLY DOES BELIEVE WHAT HE
SAYS ON THIS ISSUE.
>> Shannon: IT IS SOMETHING HE
TALKED ABOUT WAY THROUGH THE
CAMPAIGN AND IT WAS SOMETHING
PEOPLE SEEMED TO RESPOND TO.
TODAY WHEN HE BROUGHT IT UP, YOU
HEARD THE DEMOCRATS SAY IT’S
WHAT HE WANTS.
HE WANTS ANOTHER SHUTDOWN.
STILL BLAME EACH OTHER OVER THE
LAST ONE.
>> I DON’T THINK IT’S GOING TO
COME DOWN TO A SHUTDOWN ON
FRIDAY.
LAWMAKERS, EVEN THOUGH THE
PRESIDENT MADE THESE REMARKS,
ARE SAYING THEY ARE GOING TO
PASS A SHORT-TERM SPENDING
STOPGAP.
THE TIMING IS INTERESTING
BECAUSE REPUBLICAN LEADERS HAVE
BEEN TRYING FOR MONTHS TO GET
DEMOCRATS TO DROP THEIR DEMANDS.
BIPARTISAN DACA FIX IN ORDER TO
DO A LONG-TERM BUDGET DEAL THAT
GETS THE MILITARY STABILITY,
HUGE PRIORITY FOR
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP, AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
ABOUT TO CAVE ON IT THIS WEEK.
THIS IS A HUGE DEAL.
HUGE VICTORY FOR REPUBLICANS IF
THEY CAN GET DEMOCRATS TO VOTE
FOR A LONG-TERM BUDGET AGREEMENT
WITHOUT A FIX FOR DACA.
THE PRESIDENT COMING IN AND
SAYING LET’S SHUT THE GOVERNMENT
DOWN, IT HAS A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS SCRATCHING THEIR
HEADS.
>> DEPRESSED IS PLAYING THE
PRESIDENT’S REMARKS ABOUT A
SHUTDOWN AS A BIG BRAT.
IT’S NOT.
IT’S A POKE BEATING THE
DEMOCRATS.
THERE IS NOT GOING TO BE SHUT
DOWN.
I’M NOT SAYING HE WASN’T SINCERE
IN HIS COMMENTS BUT THE
DEMOCRATS PLAYED THAT CARD AND
IT WASN’T SUCCESSFUL.
THE PRESIDENT KNOWS THAT
ALTHOUGH THERE IS BROAD SUPPORT
IN THE COUNTRY FOR THE DREAMERS,
THERE IS NOT FOR SHUTTING THE
GOVERNMENT DOWN OVER THE ISSUE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER
THEY WOULD RATHER HAVE SOME KIND
OF IMMIGRATION COMPROMISE IF
INDEED IT’S POSSIBLE TO HAVE ONE
THEY WOULD PASS BOTH HOUSES OR
WHETHER THEY WOULD HAVE THE
ISSUE TO CAMPAIGN ON.
>> Shannon: ANOTHER HOT TOPIC,
THE ISSUE OF DACA, IMMIGRATION,
MS-13, FOLKS WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
LIVES AT THE HANDS ALLEGEDLY.
IN THIS CASE, WE ARE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT.
THE INDIANAPOLIS COLTS PLAYER
AND HIS UBER DRIVER WHO WAS
KILLED.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING TODAY:
"SO DISGRACEFUL THAT A PERSON
ILLEGALLY IN OUR COUNTRY KILLED
@COLTS LINEBACKER EDWIN JACKSON.
THIS IS JUST ONE OF MANY SUCH
PREVENTABLE TRAGEDIES.
WE MUST GET THE DEMS TO GET
TOUGH ON THE BORDER, AND WITH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, FAST!"
WE HAVE A FOX NEWS          FOX.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
64% SAY EXTREMELY OR VERY.
34% SAY NOT VERY OR NOT AT ALL.
RACHAEL, PEOPLE AGREE IT’S A
PROBLEM.
THEY DON’T AGREE ON THE
SOLUTION.
>> I THINK IT IS SORT OF THE
SAME THING YOU WERE MENTIONING
IN TERMS OF DEMOCRATS WANTING A
SOLUTION FOR DREAMERS BUT NOT
WANTING TO SHUT THE GOVERNMENT
DOWN OVER IT.
SAME THING WITH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THE COUNTRY BY AND LARGE, THEY
WANT A SOLUTION BUT NOT AT THE
EXPENSE OF SHUTTING DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT.
THE PRESIDENT TODAY IS TALKING
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS TERRIBLE
TRAGEDY ABOUT LOOPHOLES THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR WEEKS.
THEY SAY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE
OFTEN DEPARTED.
THE FIND A WAY BACK AND LIVE
HERE.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE
SAW WITH THIS PERSON WHO KILLED
THIS PLAYER.
REPUBLICANS WANT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
IT’S CONTROVERSIAL FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE WILLING TO TALK ABOUT
BORDER WALL MONEY BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO ACTUAL IMMIGRATION
POLICIES AND PICKING PEOPLE UP
AND PUSHING THEM OUT OF THE
COUNTRY, IT GETS MORE TENUOUS
FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> IT’S ALSO AN ISSUE POLLS
MISS.
IF YOU ARE IN FAVOR OF VISAS,
EXPANSION TO IMMIGRATION
POLICIES, THEY DON’T SUPPORT IT
WITH THE SAME INTENSITY AS
DONALD TRUMP’S BASE FIELD ABOUT
IMMIGRATION, HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THE LEVEL OF INTENSITY AND
PASSION IS SO DIFFERENT.
WE SAW IT.
THE GANG OF EIGHT SPENT SO MUCH
MORE MONEY AND THE OTHER SIDE
WON.
IN THEIR OFFICES WITH NO DONOR
MONEY, NO ESTABLISHMENT SUPPORT.
THERE IS A LOT OF PUBLIC PASSION